bon choix le disparu
si l'on vénère sa mémoire est plus
précieux et plus puissant que le vivant
l'auteur de cette phrase
antoine de saint-exupéry et bien il ya
en france au 20ème siècle 45 ans après
la seconde guerre mondiale des hommes
qui n'ont pas lu manifestement
saint-exupéry leurs lectures sont sans
doute moins glorieuse
ils sont entrés la nuit dernière dans le
cimetière juif de carpentras pour
saccager pour détruire et pour piétiner
34 tombes ont été profanées un cercueil
a été ouvert
le corps a été exhumé puis empalé
l'horreur morad aït habbouche voilà ce
qui reste du carré israélite du
cimetière de carpentras au total 34
tombes ont été profanées
le corps d'un homme enterré il ya quinze
jours seulement a même été empalé sur un
manger parasols lorsqu'ils ont appris la
nouvelle des dizaines de personnes sont
venues un ou plusieurs membres de leur
famille reposent est ici en paix
on est venu voir les tombes de départ je
vais le faire j'ai donné mon idée enfin
moi pour moi ce sont des jeunes ce sont
des débiles mentaux s'attaquait démons
je vais vous dire une chose il faut être
vraiment bas sur t1 et ces gens là je
vais vous dire les choses si vraiment il
y avait une justice d'avril d'horreur il
devrait repasser les morts c'est plus
facile certainement comme vous devez
chercher le père richesse
vous cassez ont cassé mais là vraiment
on voit que c'est c'est eh oui c'est
ouvert pour voir ce qu'il y avait dedans
condamnation unanime de la communauté
juive de la ville une des plus vieilles
de france cet après midi les policiers
ont relevé des empreintes celle de
chaussures de quatre personnes
différentes mais ce soir cet acte n'a
toujours pas été revendiqué
réaction du chef de l'état dans un
télégramme envoyé ce soir au président
du consistoire israélite de carpentras
j'apprends avec horreur écrit-il l'acte
criminel qui vient d'être commis sur le
cimetière juif de carpentras cet acte
cet attentat est particulièrement abject
à tous conclut le chef de l'état je dis
qu'il est temps de se ressaisir
nous nous y emploierons nous avons
invité le président le grand rabbin de
france pardon monsieur le grand lavage
aux instrus quelle est votre réaction
je pense que l'événement est douloureux
à trois titres
on assiste par cet horrible aux
profanations
je crois d'abord un rejet de tout ce
qu'est l'homme c'est pas un acte
antisémite
pour moi c'est l'homme qui a été atteint
ici c'est l'image de dieu sur terre
c'est une dimension spirituelle d'une
extraordinaire gravité
je pense que c'est le constat d'échec
d'une société je pense qu'il ya dans ce
monde des gens qui sont pas conscients
de ce qu'ils font on peut peut-être les
pardonner mais par contre y'a des gens
qui sont conscients de ce qu'ils disent
et c'est eux qui prépare l'inconscience
des autres nous en parlerons dans un
instant d'autres réactions politiques à
commencer par celle de pierre joxe qui
s'est rendu sur place après avoir appris
la nouvelle
le ministre de l'intérieur a exigé une
condamnation solennelle en exprimant
l'indignation l'émotion et la compassion
du gouvernement aux membres de la
communauté israélite c'était cet après
midi à carpentras de tels actes de
profanation barbares criminel aux yeux
de ce que l'humanité a de plus
spécifique
qui est le respect de la personne
humaine demande une condamnation
solennelle et indignés qui s'exprimera
j'en suis sûr à travers la france dans
les heures qui viennent et la classe
politique condamne unanimement haut-var
et indignation pour le premier ministre
michel rocard qui qualifie cette
profanation d'acte innommable
jacques chirac a fait part de son
sentiment d'horreur et d'inquiétude
georges marchais a exprimé son
indignation françois léotard a fait part
de sa profonde émotion
enfin le front national condamne la
profanation des tombes de carpentras
estime qu'il s'agit sans doute d'une
provocation
je vous propose d'écouter deux réactions
recueillies par daniel sportiello celle
de laurent fabius et de jacques barrot
je voudrais vous dire même si c'est un
peu dur à écouter ce que ça veut dire la
profanation
ça veut dire qu'il y a des gens qui sont
morts et vous qu on a souillé leurs
tombes
et ça veut dire que quand particulier
pour l'un d'entre eux on a sorti le
cadavre et on lui a enfoncé un manche de
pelle dans l'anus c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
et quand on dit cela ça veut dire que on
a voulu tuer deux fois ces gens
d'abord parce que on a commis un acte
homicide et on a voulu tuer en plus le
souvenir et la mémoire
je voudrais que on pense à ce que tous
les discours de haine raciste anti
sémitisme d'exclusion tout cela peut
conduire c'est
lamentable elle devoir de telle
profanation qui ne sont pas dignes de la
france des années 90 c'est vrai qu'il y
a dans une société qui évolue très vite
et puis qu'il doit aujourd'hui faire
face à l'intégration des étrangers venus
chez nous il y à des tentations
on n'était pas à l'index certains hommes
politiques il y à des tentations que
certains exploitent il y a ceux qui en
effet exploite les pères et les mauvais
instincts des français est bien plutôt
que de parler tous les matins de ces
gens là je veux surtout adressé mes
compatriotes et leur dire comme beaucoup
d'autres hommes politiques qui aimons
notre pays qu'il ne faut pas laisser
ternir l'image de la france par des
faits cette nature et par des
commentaires qui quelquefois semble les
encourage
monsieur grand rabat vous partager cette
analyse tout à fait s'il ya des gens
assez naïf pour croire que ce les juifs
sont visés ici il fait comme elle je
pense une grave erreur et une
civilisation qui profanent les morses
une civilisation qui demain va illuminer
les vivants je pense qu'on a vu ce matin
carpentras dans un cimetière d'une
sérénité extraordinaire talent plus
vieille communauté juive de france 1
clignotants s'allument et veut dire
attention l'histoire elle peut
recommencer
s'il y en a des nostalgiques il faut que
j'ai le courage de le dire quant à nous
si nous sommes responsables faut qu'on
se ressaisisse et qu'on sache que c'est
par une période de pédagogie de la
fraternité qu'on y arrivera et ses parts
je pense à un arrêt net de toutes les
agressions verbales il y à du non-dit
dans tout ce qui est dit est ce qu'il y
à des hommes politiques responsables
d'une manière ou d'une autre je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse dire qu'un tel
responsable ce qui est certain c'est
qu'à une responsabilité collective et
une sorte de tourbillon de spirale à
laquelle on assiste actuellement et dans
laquelle désormais celui qui se jette
près qu'à rentrer à mes yeux il y a en
france un avant carpentras et un après
qu'un contrat c'est un événement
réellement historique
je vous propose de découper la réaction
du père du puy membre de la commission
épiscopale pour les relations judéo
chrétienne écoutons le
on ne peut qu'éprouver de l'effroi
devant un acte aussi abject aussi
abominable il nous rappelle les méthodes
d'une époque qu'on croyait révolue il
s'agit sans doute d'une provocation qui
vit
à impressionner l'opinion française le
peuple juif a subi en notre époque six
millions de morts sans sépulture
il doit être particulièrement respecté
dans sa mort comme dans sa vie sans
doute le choix de la ville de carpentras
avec sa synagogue et ses souvenirs
historiques est une façon d'indiquer un
symbole le symbole un symbole auquel
nous sommes particulièrement attachés
celui d'une communauté juive de france
très ancienne ce qu'on appelait les
juifs du pas c'est probablement ce que
les agresseurs ou voulu signifier par ce
geste ignoble
mais le grand rabbin ce que vous comptez
prendre des initiatives je pense qu'il
faut d'abord alerté les pouvoirs publics
au plus haut niveau et je suis heureux
d'apprendre ici sur votre plateau ce
soir que monsieur mitterrand me fera
l'honneur ce soir d'une visite et je
pense que je lui dirai mes intentions
est-ce que je pense au niveau de
l'action que la france doit mener il
faut qu'il y ait véritablement non pas
seulement une réaction de la classe
politique non pas seulement des pouvoirs
publics et de l'opinion publique
il faut que la france se sont horrifiés
je peux vous dire que ce que vient de
dire le père du pub est allé droit au
coeur
c'est bien le créateur qui provenaient
il ya peut-être des juifs et des
chrétiens mais a qu'un dieu c'est le
même pour tous merci monsieur grand
rabbin nous y reviendrons cours de ce
journal ou cours de soir 3 les autres
événements élise frederik de klerk en
quête de respectabilité le président sud
africain est arrivé hier à paris visite
privée mais symbolique pour le président
sud africain dans la capitale des droits
de l'homme frederik de klerk été reçu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée et à matignon
pour un portage hubert coudurier et
robin touboul
un service de sécurité sur les dents
pour cette visite me prive ennemis
officiels entamé ce matin par un
déjeuner avec les dirigeants d'alstom
auquel le gouvernement sud africain
pourrait acheter une centrale nucléaire
puis une réception à l'elysée qui
témoigne que le régime de pretoria
devient à nouveau fréquentable
une heure d'entretien avec françois
mitterrand au cours de laquelle frédéric
de claire plaide la cause des réformes
sa volonté de parvenir rapidement à la
suppression de l'état d'urgence les
perspectives de modification
constitutionnelle
l'abrogation dans les six semaines à
venir de la loi sur la lutte à séparer
l'un des fondements de l'apartheid
françois mitterrand s'informe et affirme
que la france ne demande qu'à
accompagner cette évolution vers une
situation de droit pourvu qu'elle soit
le plus rapide possible prendre acte de
la volonté de réforme du président de
claire et encourager l'évolution en
cours
c'est le sens de cette réception à
l'elysée à mi chemin entre
l'intransigeance des pays scandinaves et
une certaine complaisance de la grande
bretagne qui a déjà levé les sanctions
économiques
pendant ce temps les mouvements anti
apartheid manifestent devant l'ambassade
d'afrique du sud à l'invite de nelson
mandela
sans critiquer la réception de frédéric
de plaire par la france le chef
historique de la nc encourage en effet
ses partisans à maintenir la pression
tant que l'apartheid ne sera pas
supprimé
les trois otages français encore retenus
au cabinda ont été libérés le ministère
des affaires étrangères vient de le
confirmer
ils avaient été pris en otage le 27
avril dernier par des rebelles le
cabinda en territoire congolais
européens de tous les autres continents
soyez audacieux et unissez vous c'est en
ces termes que le président de la
république tchécoslovaque vaclav havel
s'est adressé aux membres du conseil de
l'europe c'était cet après midi à
strasbourg tout de suite compte rendu de
cette journée d'un président qui s'est
permis comme il l'a dit de rêver tour
catherine boss dissidence à la
présidence de la république en passant
par la dramaturgie jusqu'au conseil de
l'europe aujourd'hui c'est le chemin du
rêve à la réalité
empruntée par vaclav havel pied de nez à
l'histoire et à ceux qui le traitaient
d'utopistes car ses rêveries d'alors
d'une europe libérée des blocs
il est venu aujourd'hui les exposer
devant l'assemblée des 23,7 euros près
dé serait une confédération qui jouerait
le rôle de maillon
les états unis et l'union soviétique
transformer d'ici là en communauté des
nations et qui est vrai pour la paix
dans le monde
pour parvenir à cela l'europe devrait se
doter de deux outils une autant
transformer voué au désarmement et la
conférence d'helsinki 2 qui pourrait se
tenir à prague
si le président du cos le bac est venu
exposer ses rêves devenus de véritables
forces de propositions devant le conseil
de l'europe
ce n'est évidemment pas un hasard
puisque pour battre la babel les valeurs
spirituelles et morales sur lesquels
repose le conseil de l'europe constitue
la meilleure base possible pour la
future europe intégrée
le conseil de l'europe qui vient
d'ailleurs d'attribuer à son pays le
statut d'observateur grâce à sa pensée
visionnaire le poète président a réussi
à tenir en haleine pendant plus d'une
heure ces vieux routiers de l'europe que
sont les membres de l'organisation de
strasbourg car comme il l'a écrit sans
rêver d'une meilleure europe on édifiera
jamais une europe meilleure
manifestation à alger aujourd'hui plus
de cent cinquante mille personnes ont
défilé dans les rues du centre de la
capitale algérienne pour la démocratie
les réparent mieux vous le voyez de très
nombreux jeunes et surtout des femmes
c'est en fait une contre manifestation
la suite du défilé des intégristes
il ya eu d'ailleurs quelques petits
incidents des jeunes intégristes ont
tenté de perturber le déroulement de
cette manifestation
mais ces incidents qui était très bref
retour en france le soleil principal
accusé des deux journées nationales de
l'eau depuis ce matin à paris
techniciens et spécialistes rencontre
mille cinq cents maires de communes de
france
une réunion qui prend un relief
particulier après deux années de
sécheresse
état des lieux du manque donc en france
dressé par christian metz il est un fait
certain que si on continue à ce régime
l'eau deviendra un problème important
même en normandie même la normandie
région arrosé s'il en est s'inquiète
désormais de son os c'est dire si
l'invitation de l'association des maires
de france et c'est révélateur de
l'association des élus du littoral pour
ces journées nationales de l'eau a été
entendu plus de 1500 communes faut
représenter des plus petites aux grandes
villes parfois inattendus comme lille
brest ou poitiers c'est que le risque de
manque d'eau est à la fois sécheresse
certes mais aussi pollutions il ne
suffit plus d'avoir de l'eau encore
faut-il qu'elle soit utilisable pour la
plupart portant les solutions évoquées
aujourd'hui et demain n'auront de
résultats que dans plusieurs années
en attendant regardez bien cette carte
les régions représentées en jaune sont
celles dans lesquelles la reconstitution
de l'habituel réserves d'eau ne s'est
pas fait autant dire que pour une bonne
partie de la france l'été s'annonce déjà
très difficile rumeurs ce matin dans le
quotidien de paris le président
d'antenne 2 2 fr3 démissionnerais a
titré ce matin le quotidien
mise au point en guise de démenti de
philippe guillôme premièrement
il ne me vient pas il ne me viendrait
jamais à l'idée de trahir la confiance
du csa qui m'a été confirmé pour trois
ans deuxièmement l'idée d'abandonner ou
de vous tromper la confiance des
salariés
l'antenne de et défaire 3 ne peut pas
non plus mais furent et si vous ce que
c'est parce qu'on veut déstabiliser en
fin de compte le service public c'est
peut-être parce que ça marche pas mal
c'est peut-être parce que le
redressement et est en cours parce qu'il
ya 5000 personnes qui témoignent
beaucoup de passion beaucoup de sérénité
beaucoup de détermination et de talent
pour remonter fidéliser l'audience et
pour progressivement nous donner les
programmes qui correspondent à nos
ambitions légitimes
michel tour et par les doutes du ciel
est ce qu'il fait mais là où il va être
cléments pour ceux qui n'aiment pas et
qui n'aime pas la pluie parce que pour
le reste vous qui attendez l'appui a
patiemment mais vous allez des chevriers
la carte des provisions matinale pour la
journée à venir
un peu de pluie sur l'extrême nord du
pays ce traître du nord pas de calais la
haute normandie jusqu'à la lorraine sur
l'extrême est c'est-à-dire de l'alsace
aux contreforts des cévennes et
jusqu'aux alpes des orages encore et
partout ailleurs le votons qui serait un
sel tout doucement nous allons vers un
beau week-end excusez-moi d'employer le
terme beau mais ce sera du soleil pour
tous et toutes quasiment merci michel
fin de ce 19 20 exceptionnel vous l'avez
compris on rend l'antenne avec du retard
à cause de la cérémonie d'ouverture du
festival de cannes dans quelques
secondes le film de jean pierre mocky le
miraculé avec jean poiret et michel
serrault et jeanne moreau
le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est à 22h30 soir 3
présenté par marc hautement bonsoir à
demain 19h bonsoir à demain